you and apples we all are Apple people
like they're taking over the world
sure whatever let the machines take over
why is everyone so afraid like Steve
Jobs is amazing
he's amazing like he's so great it was
like you know we buy all of his products
blindly blindly you know I have an
iPhone because the commercial came on
and said if you don't have an iPhone
well you don't have an iPhone and I was
like I'm not gonna be one of those
people immediately sales line so you
don't even sure it's a superior product
it's not even the best phone right but I
don't care who cares it's amazing and
everybody's got it people fit listen do
look in order to function well in
society sometimes you got to do what
everybody else is doing what's wrong
with that you know people they say
everyone else jumped off a bridge would
you do it to people don't ask questions
how high is the bridge are we going
swimming
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm saying individuality is a little
over eight it's a bit overrated yeah
yeah that's that's interesting to me now
okay in your special yeah yeah you you
and your stand up you you you swear you
swear a lot you haven't done it tonight
Offerman went crazy he went he went full
bush he went full blush didn't feel good
but but but but you you swear a bit you
say your mom doesn't like it when you
cursed has she seen your special yet
mom see she see me do stand-up she
hasn't seen the special and it's just
like I mean look it's your mom right you
you really want to make it proud and you
really want to you know you don't want
to do things that say things that will
make her like you know feel bad to feel
like she didn't do a good job raising
you and stuff you know but uh you know
I'll say chorus from time to time and
you know I get a nice gift so far she
won't be watching this thing my mother
has always been like we do anything it's
dirty my mother loves big booster of
mine big supportive we do anything and
she's like well I'd like to think that
you could get some laughs without
resorting to that kind of thing she used
to do that in the first couple of years
and she really she really does talk that
way doesn't she yes she does well I just
think would you get her like a nice
Christmas gift and she's like okay what
I would do what you got to do son I have
my agent gate or something yeah he takes
camera I'm told she's fine
you